before we before we go to break let's uh
let's go
back and let me just get your guys take
on
on this whole uh montrez herald luca
doncic thing and this is
this is what got uh montrez harold in uh
i saw that yesterday as it happened as
it developed and i guess
can we say it it's after midnight the
kiddies are all in bed
so [ __ ] ass white boy is what the
montrez harrell said and then you had
less kids moments late moments later
than they had the you know kind of the
dust up down there
um stop flopping um
so what are you uh
oh here okay this is tonight before the
game i love the whole guy
i love the fact that montrez harrell
went to him
like a man and just oh hey i apologize
i probably should i shouldn't have said
that sometimes in the heat of the moment
you say things listen we all like uh
listen
good listen sometimes we say stuff we
shouldn't say
it's all right to say i'm sorry i'm
gonna get the story right no one's
approached him and cleared the air from
all the outside nonsense that was being
said nothing but respect for luca he
understood the
heat of the battle and thank you it
didn't bother him only respect he had
talked to doc rivers
and doc had said i didn't think there
was anything racial intended
but we're in a very heightened climate
and you have to be careful
and he said i didn't mean that racially
uh well said but
yeah i think i think we've all been in
the heat of the moment
and you know and heard each other call
each other the n word
guys call each other the n word so
players not white players but
but obviously because it's a mixed race
uh you know a white
player and a black player now and and he
identified him as a white boy
uh but manchester un in the heated
moment have said some other things
probably
that he would disrespect i do think it
you know he had to apologize because it
could be viewed as a racist
comment he he had to apologize to luca
and i'm glad he did
um but it's not racism because it had no
power racism you have to have power
which means if i do something to you i
have power over you for you can't do
anything else right luca he can't stop
luca from playing in nba
can't stop him from being himself can't
stop him hitting game winners
like there's no power in what he's
saying but i'm happy that he did it
because
you know and he hopefully he learned
this because as a
african-american most of the time you
don't get
that to you someone who comes back to
you and say hey
but so i'm glad he he realized what he
could have done
and went back to him because i've never
i've been called a lot of things and no
one's ever come up to me and go oh
yo yo kitty i just want to say i that
never happens
so i'm glad that montrell understood
that apologize because he was dead wrong
in that and it was could be racist but
never racism because it had no power doc
said it best we're living in times where
people a little bit sensitive and this
thing that we do that we've been doing
we have our own rules
when we go to the gym we say a lot of
stuff that we don't mean
words like that mother effort you can't
call him you be like
we say it but we don't mean it just
because we say it don't mean we mean
yeah but the identification
that's what he's saying i know
montreal's i know he didn't mean yeah
yeah yeah
yeah he said that they all say that so
i'm gonna put that under the basketball
slang category when we playing and we
talk and smack to each other
gary payton used to say some stuff that
i ain't gonna even repeat now i used to
say some stuff but that don't mean i
don't like
you know a certain amount of people so
he apologized he did the right thing but
in this situation people trying to take
it too far yeah i think i think the
issue too is that look we've all heard
from
larry bird to dirk nowitzki to jason
williams you know and
guys are saying man that's that's one
bad white boy right there in a
predominantly black league in the
and players white players with talent
and you get that
and and that's kind of like a well it's
a compliment okay you're saying
that i can really play the game but when
it's said with
anger like this bitch-ass white boy
listen
was said that's where all the antenna
goes i just think that we all i'm sorry
i think we all have to get we're all as
african-american for me
my whole thing is i don't want to be
identified
so if we're going to ask not to be
identified i think
you know mantra i'll understand you
can't identify me they're like
because if i'd have called you if i
would just set the first part of it i'm
just angry and talking smack
i get it i get it it's a habit that you
have to break
i'm not saying i'm not saying that he
did it but it's a habit
that in sports i think we all have to
break i'm not saying that we
he didn't meant that jack and we've said
things all of us had done
that kind of lango listen it's a habit
we have to break
that's all for the moment is heat at the
moment he was 100
wrong i love the fact that he acted like
a man
chuck you never said nothing crazy on
the court i i don't ever refer to any
person upset about their color i mean
let me let me know first of all i i
listen he was wrong
and he apologized because let me tell
you something you guys are full of uh
can't say what i want to say
because if if he hadn't said that to a
black guy
you don't get to have a double standard
yeah
apologize that's a slippery slope
have you ever heard
was playing against and it was said
something that tim hardaway jr and he
said
you bitch-ass n-word should he be
which you've heard before as well so
he's identifying
not only a racial slur but identifying
it but it ain't personal
so you've heard that noah's lord so i'm
saying that we all
need to break the habit but it's not a
person all i'm going to say is
god was wrong he he apologized and it's
over with
if he shouldn't have said it listen the
reason he apologized he shouldn't have
said
that i wish had come out of this too was
that
the nba had released a statement about
this because
uh i reached out to somebody with the
nba and i said is there a statement
coming and i was just told
all we've told reporters is that the nba
addressed the situation
with montrez and he apologized i would
like to have seen
look we've we've talked to him about
this we
accepted his apology and we can't say
strongly enough that we're not going to
tolerate stuff like this
i wish i wish that had come out from the
nba
let's go to the